In addition to defining
the notion of a language itself,
we want to find some operations on
languages, and establish some notation.
We'll illustrate using these two
languages over the zero-one alphabet.
Since languages are sets, we have the
usual operations of union, intersection,
and complement.
For example, A union B consists
of these three strings,
0 from both A and B,
10 from A, and 11 from B.
The intersection contains only
those strings in both languages,
just the string 0 here.
To define the complement of a language,
we need to make clear what
it is that we're completing.
It's not sufficient just to say
that it's everything not in A.
For this particular A,
that would include strings with
characters besides 0 and 1, or
maybe even infinite sequences of 0s and
1s, which we don't want.
The complement, therefore, Is designed
so as to complete the set of all strings
over the relevant alphabet in
this case the binary alphabet.
Usually the alphabet over
which the language is defined
will be clear from context.
In this case, the complement of A will
be infinite, including the empty string,
not 0 however.
It will include 1.
It will include 00.
It will include 01.
It will not include 10 however.
It will include 11.
It will include 000, and so on and
so forth for all longer strings.
In addition to the standard
set operations,
we also define an operation for
concatenating two languages.
The concatenation of A and B is just
all strings that you can form by taking
a string from A, let's say x, and
appending to it a string y from B.
In our examples, the set AB would be 00,
the first 0 coming from A and
the second from B.
011, with the 0 coming from A and
the 11 coming from B and so forth.
Of course, we can also concatenate
a language with itself
as I've done here in this example.
Instead of writing AA,
we often write A squared.
And in general, when we want to
concatenate the language with itself
k times, we write A to the k power.
Note that for k equals 0,
this is defined as the language
containing exactly the empty string.
When we want to concatenate any number
of strings from the language together
to form a new language,
we use an operator known as Kleene star.
This can be thought of as the union of
all possible powers of the language.
When we want to exclude the empty
string, we use the plus
operator instead, which insists that
at least one string from A be used.
Notice the difference in
the starting indices.
So, for example,
this string here is in A.
There's a way that I can break it up so
that each part is in the language A.
Note that A* doesn't include
infinite sequences of symbols.
Each individual string from
a must be a finite length, and
you're only allowed to concatenate
a finite number of those together.
For those who have studied
regular expressions,
this should seem quite familiar.
In fact, one gets the notation for
regular expressions by treating
individual symbols as languages.
For example, 0* is the set of all
strings consisting entirely of 0s.
We'll also commonly refer to sigma*,
meaning all possible strings
over the alphabet sigma.